halloween is upon us people so i brought
the loudest girl with me i've ever known
tara erickson we're gonna watch
five scary ghost videos boom that will
get blue
i'll give you goosebumps tara do you
like halloween do you like horror
i love it look halloween sweater
this is a disneyland house mike is right
here there's no
need to get off halloween socks
not mess with my halloween goodness
gregory let's do this
oh yeah slightly good top five ghost
caught on camera graveyard shift
picked up user security 1275 works the
graveyard shift
literally he works as an overnight
security guard at a cemetery in savannah
georgia
this is supposed to be the most haunted
cemetery
in savannah it turns out that being an
overnight security guard at a haunted
cemetery
is just exactly as scary as it sounds
i i mean yeah i'm actually hearing
something
banging on the door
bear with me guys um okay i'm back
there was a person there yes clearly
right there
wait i've seen this video before you
have
i've seen this one this seems fake
because there
there was a person right there
yeah um
hey you need to come out i'm not playing
anymore
i'll mess you up little kid
i'll work the graveyard oh
damn what is that thing it's that person
who's
outside a child is running around in one
of the burial crips
but security 1275 can't find the
intruder
he gets cut off by tick-tock's
one-minute video upload limit as he
decides to just exit and leave the
matter for the savannah police
what security 1275 didn't notice however
is that he also caught something else on
camera
what looks to be a young child yeah
behind the wall
near the crypt how do you miss that
the lights right there
bear with me guys security 1275 posts a
follow-up video soon after this
that is just as chilling all right guys
um there were some i've seen this one
saw that my video uploaded
and
what what's he looking at the lights are
flickering on and off hang on a second
guys
so don't know what the hell is going on
here but i'm about to check this out
no okay guys
i'm really not sure what's going on here
no i don't want it
i don't want it
[Laughter]
this is why my security officer can quit
just so you all can be witness here i'm
checking on this i'm getting the hell
out of here it's my day off
no i hear this quickly
there was a kid standing somebody
standing right over here
when i walked right past them to the
left so this is this guy sounds very
convincing
around the graveyard or is it all an
elaborate hoax yeah exactly as always
you decide i mean this guy sounds very
convinced
continuing spooky experiences by
following his tick tock at security 1275
or his youtube channel security 98 86
dora the horror
unfortunately his family was
experiencing a hard time financially
and just couldn't afford to constantly
replace the doll's batteries
so instead they removed the batteries
entirely
his mom caught this video of his sister
singing and playing with the doll
oh nipple chills
what there's no batteries in that
[Music]
did it do the sound effect its mouth is
moving i
hate it so creepy i don't like it that
is so
creepy
the nameless light 209 says that the toy
was checked after they re-watched the
videos
and no batteries that's
so creepy
youtube channel the proper people is not
really a paranormal channel
in fact most of their videos are simply
devoted to exploring
strange abandoned places there's no
ghost hunting
no emf meters and no evp recordings
however over the channel's five year
history
they have explored a few allegedly
haunted locations
now both brian and i are consider
ourselves to be skeptics
we've never really experienced anything
paranormal
ourselves in this video they're
exploring the supposedly haunted desjare
asylum
before this mental hospital was closed
down it is said that the asylum founder
dr joseph desjarney
performed many dark and inhumane
experiments
on his captive patients so they say this
hospital
is haunted by dr desjarnette himself and
supposedly you can still hear him
wandering the halls
dragging chains that he would have
restrained patients with
soon after you guys experience something
absolutely terrifying
what's up i thought i heard something
apparently
like footsteps
i mean it's a big building there could
be homeless people in there right
look at all the graffiti yeah there's
obviously like
dancing oh what wait what
you can hear that no no what
turn off your flashlight i hate all of
it why are you going down and now why
would you go down
and not out
it's like cute
wow this is terrifying
being skeptics the two assumed they
might have stumbled onto a homeless
person living in the abandoned asylum
that was a person
like a homeless person or something he
was a law there were a lot of footsteps
though those footsteps were super loud
maybe they were dragging something the
proper people investigate
but find no one in the building why
consuming the whole incident to simply
be homeless people who are now hiding
from them
they decide to make their exit however
youtube commenters noticed something a
bit strange in the video
what some background noise that sounds a
bit like whispering
occurs right before the creepy footsteps
i mean we've already been all through
here i know you didn't see it
they're moving that way now obviously
the guys would be lightly whispering
incoherently so just what is their
camera
picking up some of their viewers believe
that they did have a paranormal
encounter
after all but what do you think
you can see the rest of this video
including their investigation of the
upstairs footsteps
over on their youtube channel the proper
people
[Music]
room with a view
even though she's working alone even
creepier
she says that once when her son came to
visit her at work
he went off exploring only to come back
screaming and in tears because as he put
it
quote something is whispering my name
building residents have reported similar
chilling stories
one day they catch something very
bizarre on the apartment complex oh no
what is that
what is it something
oh we missed it i'm getting back
what you see it where little smidge
what is that it's a smidge right here
what is that is that 121 right i think
so
what's gonna happen oh
what the [ __ ]
that was crazy right yes that's just
crazy
fell off just gets even
what is that another day and the cctv
captures this in the same area what
oh good lord okay
is is something actually moving or is
that just my eyes i can't say
nothing's moving right now there it is
you see it
no on the ground this little thing like
the ghost thing
what is that yeah the doorway i saw that
something exits the room yes and
disappears it does that's weird building
manager says
i don't like it
but nevertheless the strange occurrences
continue
why would you stay there over his head
never stayed
as a croatian youtuber who does a little
bit of everything on his youtube channel
including an occasional bit of ghost
hunting
in this video his friend tells him about
her creepy experience in an abandoned
haunted house
she mentions that the house has an
incredibly haunted
spooky addict
after they heard bizarre scratches on
the ceiling
so dennis decides to explore the place
himself
including the attic that he was told was
too haunted to enter
it doesn't go well
[Music]
what happened
what since the stairs you can actually
hear heavy footsteps running toward him
across the atlantic floor
really
oh
what the hell is that sound fleece the
house is the big screaming devil
or is that is one of them saying devil
uh
oh i don't know was there something evil
in that attic
let me know what you think guys the dora
one's easily number one
the other ones are eerie and
uncomfortable fairy
but the dora wants the scariest one man
uh-oh hey christilia he's beloved
oh gosh wow tara
i'm going to start making spooky videos
you know you're excited you're funny
he has some pretty funny lines in there
dora still had batteries in her okay
there was a
string tied somebody turned her head i'm
a skeptic too
except for the people's people i
believed them that there was those weird
i could hear it i did not hear
whispering like the whisperings from the
guy behind the camera oh so how did that
security guy not see that kid standing
there
if he makes spooky videos all the time
security one two seven
five he's setting him up he's bored on
his graveyard it's a
if he i didn't i've seen this video
before
this that that first one i'm saying i've
seen that before i'm always
skeptical when it's especially when the
channel they do
is dedicated to fighting they're
defining paranormal stuff
yeah and they're like well you need it
because that's your whole gimmick you're
supposed to find these things
you know like if i needed to find cbd
lotion i would say
just hide this yeah you can smoke this
lotion let's go find it
i knew today i hadn't thought of i
should put this away because somehow
tara's gonna just
spot this and put it on camera i got it
from whole foods
whole foods it's good cbd is good for
you put it on my shoulder had shoulder
pain earlier
that made me a million times more
skeptical although the if it is fake the
performance is very good he's
very believable yeah like this guy
should get an acne career if he is
faking it i agree
murphy's like i don't know why i just
don't quit my job
but make more money on these youtube
views and being here also when he's like
this is my day off i'm like why are you
there
you know these like instagram posts of
like nurses and teachers who are getting
fired for having an only fan's account
yeah do you think his guy would get
fired i know right
of course he has 154.1k fans
he has to but the door one was really
creepy
especially with even without the sound
effect of
the doll turning its head look what i
was saying what is that
those are strings i think those are just
lens flares oh
you might be right i think that's just
the fact that
that's a tv that is
is over there turning your head i don't
believe it that's spooky as hell
the doll already looked creepy which
kind of surprised me because the design
a door is generally like an adorable
sign
yes but that one like all right away or
like there's something like messed up
about that dorado it's one of sid's toys
from toy story that's what he would play
with no battery that is like
traditional horror movie crap right
there with the little kids still playing
with the doll and still in love with it
and then
the doll turned to her like get away
from her
i would have believed it i'm like just
fine
keep rolling take the batteries out same
shot
buddy come on now it was very clear it
was like 4k
footage of the batteries coming out and
1990 footage of dora turning right here
you have to do one take of just you guys
no batteries yeah you got to show it you
already gotta close up to it
but though like the one with the proper
people
that's spooky because they are like
they're skeptics so i believe them
and i did hear that above them and i if
it's only two guys always all the time
in their videos that sounded clearly
right above their head
i mean that was the most uncomfortable
one because you really do start
suspecting something's gonna pop out
especially when you're just in the pov
shot of them running around and it's
just so creepy in there
but the thing you gotta really factor in
is it's probably just a homeless guy
look like look at
all the graffiti so there's people in
there
doing their art on a daily basis
discussing things probably
sleeping doing some stuff some some
juicy
gross things could just be that but then
there's that part of me that's going if
you're in there to capture something
don't [ __ ] out right go run up the
stairs
risk your life risk being killed risk
being murdered for
this video i mean what's the point if
you're not gonna confirm anything
you're gonna get once you're done once
you're dead just have it set to
automatically
upload for all you know
what could have been in there were two
other youtubers
who were looking to try to find the same
thing and they just freaked each other
out
also they ran down instead of up and the
sounds were coming up and i'm like go up
the stairs
capture that capture it man it's the
whole reason you're there
capture it i guess it makes sense that
they went down because
i might not want to run towards it the
hotel one that was freaky
i don't want it it's looked like a cat
but it looked like a vase
what was that the thing on the about
under the mirror you're talking about
yes
it was like a vase but then it looked
like it turned into a cat and then it
just broke
i don't know man i don't know why you'd
still work there too
like why are these people still working
here i think it'd be fun to actually
stay at one of those haunted hotels to
see if something would happen oh heck
yeah that'd be fun
the queen mary is apparently haunted in
long beach you could stay there
i would love to go there and be haunted
but i tell you i bet you i would go
there and there would be no hauntings
yeah that's the thing you gotta like
believe in it and get the juices flowing
and then you start thinking you see
stuff
you think the ghosts would know about
the security cameras too i think number
one
with the what are the croatian people oh
yes is that right croatia
i think so i don't know we are dumb
americans
we don't know other cultures we don't
know that one was a bit of a letdown to
me because
i i actually couldn't quite discern who
was like they heard a noise in footsteps
yeah that was it but
was going to the yelling yelling or was
that the person yelling see because he
pointed his camera up right yeah and
then it it was like a sound and it was
like run run but it sounded like the
girl was still behind him and then
someone's going
yeah yeah yeah that could have been
added that's what i'm saying i don't
skip
i don't feel like it was in the moment
cause why don't you go up those stairs
that's true see you get me you feel me
it's spooky it is spooky but i'm like
you gotta go
up all the things you have to go up the
stairs and they didn't do that so tara
tell me
out of all these which one would you
believe was a real
spooky hotel hotel that was cct
footage that's that one that one i i i
super believe
oh and the people's people the problems
the proper people
those two young americans the people's
people right there have you guys
registered to vote yet uh i believe them
because he looked actually terrified and
then he also was just asking the
you think it's like it's like a homeless
person right but we checked all of it
he sounded legit terrified so i really
believe that i it probably was a
homeless person but
those footsteps kind of boom yeah
and it adds to the eeriness of the once
it finally
came close to capturing something
they're like let's get out of here
terrifying
i don't know why we came here all right
well nukes top five thanks for putting
that video together this was a great one
tara you really made me laugh on this
i loved it subscribe to tara erickson's
channel check her out hey
subscribe notification bells
like the button and subscribe leave a
comment
zack with an h fifo three pledged to our
patreon a little late in the month and i
thought we were all done with our patron
of the day
shout outs but managed to get in there
when one spot opened up
zach traditional shout out time
z stands for zephyr
because you make me want to fly with you
on a zephyr
oh yes and a stands for
abominable because you are
colossal and and and and and horrifying
to behold but also majestic
all right abominable snowman yes sir
c stands for
creative ooh because i imagine you're
one with a creative sensibility
and h stands for
hell of a guy you're a hell of a guy
zach
thank you zach for being you for being
here
you've literally earned this shot
you've attacked my zacks thanks buddy
you